tous leurs efforts
l'élection va démarrer bien sûr dans 20
on a un gros souci des cherry je
m'adresse à vous si vous voyez un garçon
pas très réveillé en train de se
promener dans les rues de boulogne
billancourt où se trouve le studio
vieillit lui indiquer son choix
cette personne s'appelle bruno ont connu
sous le nom de doc gynéco il devait
venir aujourd'hui je veux dire vous êtes
son assistant dont vous êtes vous le
coller à la culotte bien c est ce que
vous avez des news
aucune nouvelle la banda fois que vous
l'avez vu j'étais quand je lis au
téléphone cet après midi à kehl à 14
heures oui après 14 heures ils étaient
treize enfants
oui il m'a dit qu'il était avec avec toi
ont rendez vous à 14 heures mais pas
loin non plus et paris où ils devaient
être là 18 heures mais qu'on a pris le
scooter ouais j'ai suivi ouais et d'un
coup il a dit je n'ai jamais fait de
connaître et si j a quitté le plateau
c'est uniquement car je n'arrivais pas
en placer une j'ai levé le bras droit à
un moment donné car mon biceps a été
déchiré en 2015
je suis obligée de soutenir mon bas si
les levées et oui je l' ai tendu car il
était fatigué après cinq heures de
voiture pour aller dans cette émission
gilles verdez et je vais vous montrer
les images dans un instant vous allez
voir dans quelle manière on va vous
démontrer c'est du foutage de gueule
intégral il tente de s'en sortir parce
qu'il faut bien expliquer qu un salut
nazi c'est un délit dont il peut être
condamné il tente de trouver une
explication totalement fantaisistes il a
vraiment voulu faire ça et d'ailleurs
quand il parle en quittant le plateau
mais oui je les fais il assume mois il
assume et regarder quand sa voisine dont
il masque lui demande de s'expliquer le
pneumologue donc patrick bédié reconnaît
sans concession avoir fait ils n'ont pas
une quenelle mais un salut nazi
regardez
merci merci mes conneries merci s'il
vous plaît merci s'il vous plaît oh
[ __ ]
alors j'ai un petit problème je suis
obligé de vous le montrer parce qu'ils
se moquent de moi qu'est-ce qui se passe
non je vais vous montrer parce que ma
venait derrière l'automate
[Applaudissements]
moi je pense que neymar a dit la vérité
est que la chaîne télé foot tu es pro
marseillaise de cacher leur sont pro
marseillais tu es les fautes ils l'ont
dit noah si l'on bat ils l'ont dit mais
il va bien m
[Applaudissements]
quillan et paris l'ont dit il a donné tu
sais qu'ils le tuent c'est qui le
président de la chaîne c'est qui oui
c'est jean michel roussier qui était
l'ancien président de l'om mais c'est
pas du tout pour ça qu'ils sont partis
alors si tu vas paramétrer que la bruine
et le papa tu veux par la bombe et chéri
vous avez jean pierre pernaut va quitter
jt tf1
après ça a été un crève coeur
un crève coeur mais ici on a peut-être
le remplaçons nous a donné rendez vous
mardi dans son village pour nous faire
découvrir sa recette d'agneau revisitée
qui ne laisse pas indifférent les petits
comme les qualités d'un reportage sur 24
et ce parce que compass c'est dans une
ferme des flandres cantona vient
chercher ses fruits et légumes et son
choix se porte aujourd'hui sur des
asperges qu'il va marier avec
l'incontournable de pâques chocolat
[Applaudissements]
vous dites non ils sont potes ne sont
pas accompagnés les gens de télé mais
non c'est ce qu'en rapporte de toute
façon c'est un système qui est comme ça
je veux dire on travaille depuis des
années moi ça fait 35 ans que sur les
télévisions et à rapporter quoi en 35
ans
[Applaudissements]
g
la plus importante que l'on puisse
donner un spectateur le bonheur le dire
sans prétention qu'on a besoin de vous
bernard montiel est arrivé les pensées
dont il s'agit est ce qu'on parle d'un
animateur qui n'est qu'à nîmes vb naïve
là on va pas rentrer on dit que vous
êtes trop payés mais à ce moment là chez
vrai nom les rendez l'argent les babines
au rang des dangers de réduction des
coûts réels négatifs et maintenant tu
sais de l'argent vous payez des impôts
oui donc ici vous faites mais n'essayez
pas de me défendre de merde
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
bernard montiel qui va arriver dans un
instant à votre question bouger à tanger
au bourget privés ont partir marrakech
soit saint-tropez
bon c'est vrai qu'on est bien sûr bah
oui quoi quoi et donc hier soir qu'il va
jet privé pour partir en week end
by par lci leur éthique et sur un moto
taxi il est riche à ce poids là pas du
tout à trac l'histoire était gravité
mais qui a dû aller à monaco
voilà c'est le maire en jet mais non
c'est pas le prince albert a si c'est
pas du tout va bien sur quoi ces pages
qu ils pensent ils étaient sûrs et là y
pensez-vous de bernard il est très riche
jelen dans le cachet
[Applaudissements]
non mais qu'est ce que c'est bon je me
rends compte au bout de onze ans que je
travaille avec une bombe de baisser cela
dit des choses très méchante sur mon ami
bernard montiel savoir établir la vérité
qui est maintenant seulement ils ne
payent rien nulle part mais s'il peut
prendre un petit billet en plus et des
panneaux
[Applaudissements]
savage par mois
on dirait le public des chiffres et des
lettres vous êtes réveillé
[Applaudissements]
oh oui merci beaucoup c'est loin il
n'était qu'un dont il revient dessus ou
tété ou chez sa grand mère
je
un showmatch monaco monaco y aller
retour avec tagro mais je vous avez fait
quoi là bas je sais que je savais qu'une
boîte de communication
j'avais conseil quelqu'un à flaine
d'allers retours dans la journée et
j'avoue que c'est crevant et ça c'est
formidable
ouais c'est formidable tu gagnes de la
thune
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je crois qu'on a que c'est le meilleur
c'est terminé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu as
je viens
on
mais bon
[Musique]
des ailes aux voyages sont les joies
et voilà 250 millions
[Applaudissements]
à temps
[Musique]